guys Faker is one series Away From
Another World title six years after his
last but to win it all this weekend he
has to get past Deft perhaps the only
other person at this tournament who's
had more of an anime storyline than him
I cannot wait
okay we are really really zoning in now
on 2 million subscribers we're basically
almost there I tell myself we're already
there but the truth is we're not we need
your help to just put us over the finish
line so if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the score Esports and if
you enjoyed this video leave us a like
on your way out the door cheers alright
so let me take you all back to March
this year when I said this I don't want
to get too carried away here obviously I
know it's only March but but if Faker
does win Wells this year and then he
retires you're going to want to say you
were here for it now to be honest I was
intentionally being a little bit
dramatic there but Faker and T1 had just
broken an incredible record by going
15-0 in spring in the lck they made it
18-0 soon after achieving the first ever
perfect split in that League they were
just smashing everyone the faker hype
train was real everyone was on it I was
on it maybe I was even driving it you
can't prove that that's why around that
time even though it was about seven
months away I was already talking about
the possibility of T1 and Faker winning
worlds this year Faker last one world in
2016 and since then a lot of people had
sort of written him off sure he was the
goat but we couldn't really see him
lifting the summoner's cup again could
we now back when Faker was just [__]
on everyone in Spring I said that T1 and
Faker fans shouldn't get too excited and
get too ahead of themselves a lot can
change between spring and summer after
spring despite making it to MSI finals
they fell to RNG in a close series which
went the distance it was the first best
of five T1 had lost that year they
dusted themselves off with a strong
start to the summer split but by the end
of the regular round robin they were
trailing slightly to an imperious
looking Genji T1 had beaten Genji in the
spring finals and it was the same
matchup again for the summer finals only
this time Genji crushed them this is
desperately trying to hold on he does go
golden himself but look at these messes
Carson for the first time Genji will
crack a third Nexus
that 3-0 sweep by Genji place them as
the undoubtable kings of the lck and one
of the favorites to win Worlds T1 were
bruised by this but not broken they
might not have been the favorites going
into Worlds but they were still coming
off the back of an incredible year and
Vega was still Faker they topped their
group with a 5-1 record only dropping a
surprise game to fnatic but 2-0 in Cloud
9 and last year's Champions EDG now all
of this wasn't too surprising yet
everyone expected T1 to at least get out
of groups but sweeping MSI Champions RNG
3-0 and dominating LPL Champions jdg
were not on most people's cards for The
Knockout stage that series also provided
a clip that you will see in every single
highlight reel when Faker finally does
retire one with 40 seconds till the
straight comes up about the same time
they find the rest 369 going to take his
fight against Faker will it be enough
does he win round two he's ignited he's
never from
with
the one on one there goes now he's got
more enemies coming after him though
he's going for the sneaky recall out of
vision they know he's on the left-hand
side missing will not spot him going to
the brush they see they
[Applause]
and he did that on Rise one of his
all-time signature Champions I don't
know how much the scriptwriters are
getting paid for this but they need a
raise seriously even jdg Banning rise in
the final game couldn't stop Faker who
reminded everyone just how disgusting
his azir is six nine fights death number
four with the re-engagement
[Applause]
The unkillable Demon King rebuild his
throne with the skulls of his enemies
with that semi-final win over jdg Faker
has now reached a place he hasn't been
in half a decade as this handy graphic
from Riot shows after his Golden Era of
winning worlds Faker has struggled to
even get back to the finals in recent
years never mind win the whole thing and
here you can see just how much has
changed around him since his first world
Title by Mike out Faker has had no less
than 27 teammates since 2013. true t1's
Peaks and troughs he's been the only
constant and now almost 10 years after
his first World's title Faker has
reached the ultimate game of League of
Legends once again and even if you don't
support T1 even if you don't watch the
lck even if you weren't there for
faker's Glory Days it feels like
everyone's a little bit of a faker
Fanboy right now Aussie yelling at the
TV the whole time cheering bro they I
won I got up with like a huge smile like
I'm talking I had I had my face like
this close to the TV I was like you're
that dude like I was just yelling you're
here bro let's go
I got a little bit light-headed too
Alice height
that was height dude that was a good
Saturday
all right his faker's that guy that's my
GoPro
since it says you really can't vote
yourself for the goat conversation we
all know I'm the goat but
that's my goat dude it really does feel
like an anime storyline but incredibly
it's not the only anime storyline of
Worlds because of deft in 2014 the year
after faker's first World's appearance
this Korean 80 carry made his own
world's debut that year he made it to
semi-finals with Samsung blue before
being knocked out by their sister team
in Samsung white who would go on to win
the tournament now around this time it
was widely agreed that death was one of
the best 80 carries on the planet but he
could never quite replicate his
explosive entrance onto the scene he
reached quarterfinals in 2015 2016 2018
and 2020 all incredible accomplishments
in their own right but 2022 marks eight
years since his last semi-finals Peak
this year he and his team DRX finished
sixth in the regular season got knocked
out in the quarter-finals of playoffs
and scraped the lck's fourth seed of
world through the regional finals that
meant they had to battle through the
playing stage at Worlds which they did
pretty comfortably without dropping a
single game but people didn't really
expect them to make too many waves at
the main event this was the lck's fourth
seed and a team that hadn't really
impressed all year they came out on top
of their group with a 4-2 record
dropping games to Rogue and top Esports
along the way they saw them face off
against defending Champions EDG in the
quarter-finals who ended up taking a 2-0
lead in the series against them after
the most insane inhibitor respawn stop
death from ending the second game
[Applause]
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous it
looked like another quarterfinals bow
out for Deft but once again the
scriptwriters have been working overtime
in probably one of the most incredible
comebacks of all time DRX reverse swept
edg-3-2 it was only the second ever
reverse sweep in world's history when
death was reminded of the fact that it
had been
2942 days since he last made it to World
semi-finals he broke down in tears oh
and did I mention that all of this
happened on his birthday
ridiculous their semi-finals opponent
was Genji Genji as in the lck Champions
JG as in one of the favorites to win
Worlds peanuts shovi ruler that whole
gang as vedius showed on the broadcast
almost every statistic from the past two
years of these two teams facing off in
the lck pointed in favor of Genji Genji
were 13-0 against DRX going into this
series but Deft and friends were growing
in strength with every game and when it
came down to it Genji completely
crumbled shout out to zika for an
incredible series too I wish I had time
to break down that game and that whole
series but the point is Deft has done it
he's made it to a World's final for the
first time ever it's his first shot at
the title and it's gonna be against
Faker both of these stories have felt
like anime arcs two veterans who have
been written off by people in their own
ways here together again at the end of
it all in fact the only thing that could
make this feel feel more anime perhaps
is I don't know if they went to the same
High School
they went to the same high school yes
for those who don't already know in a
2019 interview within van Global Faker
and death talked about how they both
attended mapo High School in Seoul at
the same time death had heard about
Faker and already knew of him he was
already number one on the solo queued
ladder but Faker had never heard of deft
there's been some comparisons to Pokemon
floating about here and yeah it really
does feel like that that's final
challenge to get what he's been looking
for after all these years is to take
down that kid from his high school a
decade ago it's getting to a point now
in this video and also in general where
there's just no words anymore you could
talk all day about how Fate has brought
these players together once again on
Lee's grandest stage but at the same
time nothing really needs to be said
anymore the time for talking is over now
they just need to play in any of the
Year Faker and the Magnetic fate that
has brought the goat back to a World's
final would have been the only thing we
need to talk about here but Fate has
given us death as well a Grizzle veteran
who's somehow unlocking new levels
inside of himself and is surrounded by a
team that is starting to believe this
weekend one of them will have a fairy
tale ending to their story the other
will write another bitter chapter I love
both stories I love both players I love
everything about this match and I think
that's why it's so hard to choose who to
root for but whoever comes out on top
whoever lifts that summoner's cup I
think we're in for one hell of a final I
was struggling to find the words to end
this and then I watched a video by the
very talented silver XS hopefully I got
their name right there of death talking
about Faker and it really hit the spot
see you soon
foreign
[Music]